unglaublich die medizin hat jahrhunderte
ein organ übersehen und es ist nicht
irgendein organ sondern ein komplettes
gefäßsystem die blutbahn bot alles über
das jetzt in klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen ja es ist geschehen
violett ihr habt whatsapp so gewünscht
und hier sind sie die violetten haare
zur feier von zweieinhalb millionen
views auf youtube auf dienstag haben
können das jetzt noch in der story sehen
linke ist in der video beschreibung zum
thema wie bitte die medizin hat seit
jahrhunderten ein komplettes gefäßsystem
im körper übersehen wie konnte das
passieren
konkret geht es um das intern stets in
den zwischenraum mit diesen auch
bindegewebe genannten zellen konnte die
medizin bisher nichts anfangen aber
darin verbirgt sich wohl ein komplettes
system mit einer unbekannten flüssigkeit
entdeckt wurde ist bei der untersuchung
mit einem neuartigen endoskop bei der
untersuchung an der new york university
school of medicine fiel im gallengang
ein netzwerk vieler mit flüssigkeit
gefüllte hohlräume auf das in keinem
fach buch beschrieben ist nie leise von
der school of medicine untersuchte
weiter und stieß achtung im ganzen
körper auf dieses system von dam bis zur
haut überall dort ist es zu finden wo
sich gewebe bewegt zusammengedrückt wird
oder pulsiert in der medizin war schon
lange klar dass irgendwo im körper noch
zusätzliche flüssigkeit sein müsse nur
gefunden hat sie niemand es wurde
irgendwo in den zwischenräumen vermutet
zahlreiche funktionen könnte das neu
gefundene system haben körpereigene
abwehr eine art dämpfer funktion für
organe und anderes gewebe und der schutz
vor alterungsprozessen aber wie kann es
sein dass im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert ein solch riesiges system
einfach immer noch übersehen werden
konnte ich finde das total verrückt und
die erklärung ist ebenso ich sage mal
bescheuert denn gewebe wird ja schon
seit menschengedenken unter dem
mikroskop untersucht der casus knaxus
liegt in der behandlung der gewebeproben
vor dem mikroskop ihren jeweils wird das
gewebe nämlich so behandelt dass das
investitions behandlung zerstört wird
die kanäle kollabieren zur
unkenntlichkeit das system ist
verschwunden
zitat unsere entdeckung hat
das potenzial dramatische fortschritte
in der medizin herbeizuführen
unter anderem könnt ihr die analyse
interstitial flüssigkeit ein wertvolles
diagnose werkstatt werden so kaiser
das ist wirklich der wahnsinn krebs
könnte in zukunft besser therapiert
werden oder das bilden von metastasen
komplett unterbunden werden cellulite
könnte vielleicht der vergangenheit
angehören und und und absoluter wahnsinn
wenn er als erstes neues dazu und da
wird es in zukunft oder bald schon eine
menge infos geben und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert und ihr
bekommt direkt auch ein kleines goodie
seid gespannt der direkte draht zu mir
einfach mehr drauf kriegen und natürlich
nicht das aber mit der glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter auch dafür
draufklicken kunst organe aus dem 3d
drucker kunst vagina erfolgreich
implantiert ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran